everyone and thank you for being here
today it's my pleasure to introduce
Secretary of Defense Lloyd Austin III
and chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff General Mark milley the secretary
and the chairman will each deliver
opening remarks and then we'll have time
to take a few questions I will moderate
those questions and call on journalists
and would ask that we limit follow-ups
due to our tight schedule
thank you for your assistance with that
and over to you secretary Austin
well good afternoon everyone and thank
you all for joining us today at Ramstein
we've just completed the eighth Ukraine
defense contact group meeting
and it was great to start the new year
by
deepening our coordination as we work
together for
Ukraine's self-defense
as President Biden has said
this is a decisive decade for the world
and this is a decisive moment for
Ukraine's struggle to defend itself
so this contact group will not slow down
we're going to continue to dig deep and
based upon the progress that we've made
today
I'm confident that Ukraine's partners
from around the globe
are determined to meet this moment
the United States remains committed to
leading in this coordinated effort
and this morning I was pleased to
announce
another major round of U.S security
assistance
designed to meet Ukraine's urgent
Battlefield requirements
and this 2.5 billion dollar package is
one of our largest yet
it helps Ukraine meet its air defense
needs
with additional May Sams munitions
and eight Avenger air defense systems
in this package also helps
tackle Ukraine's urgent need for armor
and combat vehicles
it includes 59 additional Bradley
infantry fighting vehicles
and 90 Striker armored personnel
carriers
53 M reps
and 350 up armored Humvees
and it will provide thousands around
thousands more rounds of artillery
now we were honored uh to hear this
morning from president zielinski of
Ukraine
and let me also thank several other
Brave Ukrainian leaders for joining us
today
and that includes
my good friend Minister Alexi reznikov
the minister of defense
and Lieutenant General moishuk
the deputy chief of Defense
their presentations gave us a firsthand
account
of what Ukraine's military and citizens
are facing
today's meeting focused on Ukraine's
needs for air defense and armor
we also pushed hard on how to
synchronize those donations
and turn them into fully operational
capabilities
and that means
every step from donation
to training to maintenance and then to
sustain it
we also focused hard on how our
Collective and and individual training
efforts would be prosecuted
so
as you heard President Biden recently
announced the latest U.S training
initiative
and it builds on U.S programs to train
Ukrainian troops dating back to 2014.
other countries are stepping up with
their own initiatives and many are
joining the European unions
military assistance mission
Meanwhile we're also continuing to
strengthen our defense industrial bases
through the work of the national
armaments directors
under the auspices of this contact group
and all of these efforts underscore how
much we've deepened our cooperation
since the contact group began last April
our work shows how much nations of
Goodwill can achieve when we work
together
and it shows our long-term commitment to
supporting Ukraine
against
Russia's unprovoked aggression
now as we saw again just days ago in
nepro
Russia continues its assault on Ukraine
civilian and and critical infrastructure
and Russia continues to bombard
Ukraine's cities with cruise missiles
and drones
but the Ukrainian people stand defiant
and strong
and Ukrainian troops are bravely
defending their country and their fellow
citizens
as Russia's cruelty deepens
the resolve of this contact group grows
and that's clear from the announcements
that we've heard today and I'll start
with air defense
several countries have come forward with
key donations that will help protect
Ukraine skies and cities and citizens
France Germany and the UK have all
donated air defense systems to Ukraine
and that includes a patriot battery from
Germany
and that's especially important coming
alongside our own contribution of our
Patriot system
and the Netherlands is also donating
Patriot missiles and launchers and
training
meanwhile Canada has procured a nasam
system
in Associated Munitions for Ukraine
and so these air defense systems will
help save countless innocent lives
we're also pushing hard to meet
Ukraine's requirements for tanks and
other armored vehicles
the UK has announced a significant
donation of Challenger 2 tanks for
Ukraine
this is the first introduction of
Western Maine battle tanks into Ukraine
may also commend our British allies for
for making this decision
if Sweden announced it's donating the
cd-90 Infantry fighting vehicles
and an additional donation soon of
Archer howitzers
you've also heard inspiring and
important new donation announcements
from several other countries and and
that includes Denmark which will donate
19 howritters
in Latvia is donating more stingers and
helicopters and other equipment
and Estonia is providing Ukraine with a
significant new package of much needed
155 millimeter howitzers and munitions
now all of today's announcements our
direct results of our work at the
contact group
and these important new commitments
demonstrate the ongoing resolve of our
allies and partners to help Ukraine
defend itself
because this isn't just about Ukraine's
security
it's also about European security
and it's about Global Security
it's about the kind of world that we
want to live in
and it's about the world that we want
our children and grandchildren to
inherit
the members of this contact group are
standing up
for a world where where rules matter
and where rights matter
and where sovereignty is respected
and where people can choose their own
path
free from tyranny and aggression
and I'm confident that this group
will remain United
and we'll continue to build momentum
we'll support Ukraine against Russian
aggression for the Long Haul
and we'll continue to work toward a free
and security right Ukraine in a stable
and decent world
and with that let me turn it over to the
chairman for his comments
good afternoon everyone and thank you
secretary Austin for your leadership in
this uh eighth Ukrainian contact group
in support of uh Ukrainian freedom and
thanks as well to all the ministers and
the chauds the chiefs of defense that
we're here who represented 54 different
countries today
a special thank you also to Ukrainian
Minister defense uh rizikov and Deputy
Chief of Defense General moisick I had
recently had an opportunity to meet with
General zaluzny in Poland and uh General
moisick was here representing him they
all represent the exceptional bravery of
the Ukrainian Army and most importantly
uh the Ukrainian people this week after
meeting General zaluzia had an
opportunity to visit some of the
training in the mech infantry that we
are doing at grafenwehr here in a
training area in Germany also an
opportunity to do some coordination
meetings at Wiesbaden and then attended
the NATO Chad's military committee
meeting where all the members of all the
trials of NATO had an opportunity to
meet with one of the primary topics
being support to Ukraine and then of
course this week ending it today this
week with uh with the contact group I
think that over my 43 years in uniform
this is the most unified I've ever seen
NATO and I've dipped in and out of NATO
over many many years
the war has evolved over the last 11
months but the mission of this group
this contact group under General
Austin's leadership under secretary
Austin's leadership has remained the
same we are effectively committed to
support Ukraine with capabilities to
defend itself against the illegal and
unprovoked Russian aggression
in the words of President Biden
secretary Austin and many other national
leaders
as much as it takes for as long as it
takes in order to keep Ukraine free
independent and sovereign
these contact group meetings play an
important role as we support Ukraine in
the defense of its territory and they
are a clear unambiguous demonstration of
the unity and resolve of the Allied
Nations
yesterday
as secretary Austin just mentioned
President Biden released our
30th security assistance package
signifying our continued commitment to
Ukraine this package combined with our
previous one
includes combined arms maneuver
capabilities with supporting artillery
equivalent to at least to combined arms
maneuver brigades or six Mech infantry
battalions
10 motorized infantry battalions
and four artillery battalions along with
a lot of other equipment this package
this U.S package along with the Allied
donations that were indicated today
signify our Collective resolve and our
commitment to Ukraine to protect their
population
from the indiscriminate Russian attacks
and to provide the armor necessary to go
on the offensive
to liberate Russian occupied Ukraine
additionally this week in Germany we
began Battalion and Brigade collective
training that I had an opportunity to
visit
at the combined house maneuver Training
Center
here in Grafenberg in support of the
Ukrainian Army
that training in addition to the
equipment will significantly increase
ukrainian's capability to defend itself
and further Russian attacks
and to go on the Tactical and
operational offensive to liberate the
occupied areas
with the training that the United States
and our partners are doing
the ukrainians will advance their
command and control their tactics
techniques and procedures their ability
to integrate fires with maneuver and
they will more effectively synchronize
all of the combined arms in order to
execute maneuver-based operations
the support that we discussed today in
this contact group meeting the training
that we discussed today and the way
ahead
it's really an extension of what's been
going on since 2014.
and today signifies a very real and
tangible difference in the Ukraine's
efforts to defend itself
International aggression where large
countries use military force to attack
small countries and change recognize
borders cannot be allowed to stand
eventually
President Putin Russia will realize the
full extent of their strategic
mascaculation
but until Putin ends this war his war of
choice
the nations of this contact group will
continue to support the defense of
Ukraine in order to uphold the
rules-based international order thank
you and welcome your questions thank you
Mr secretary chairman our first question
will go to Utes from Ard
hello Mr Secretary of Defense my
question is many of us thought that
today we will have a breakthrough in the
discussion about heavy metal tanks
you didn't mention that at all we didn't
talk about Leo part 2 or everyone's
tanks so did you talk about that today
uh I think you heard you may have heard
the German Minister of Defense say
earlier that they've not made a decision
on the provision of leopard tanks uh
we're really focused on
is making sure that uh Ukraine has a
capability uh that it needs to be
successful right now so we have a window
of uh opportunity here uh you know
between now and the spring when I you
know whenever they commence uh their
operation they're counter offensive uh
and that's not a long time and we have
to pull together the right capabilities
and you've heard that the chairman walk
through uh some of the substantial
combat power that we and and some of our
allies have uh have offer offered to
provide
uh there are tanks in that uh in that uh
those offerings uh Poland for example it
continues to offer tanks and will
provide tanks in other countries will
offer some take capability as well I
don't have any announcements to make on
him ones and you heard the uh the German
Minister of Defense say that uh they've
not made a decision on leopards
next question will go to Idris Ali
Reuters
Mr secretary over the past week a number
of European countries have publicly
pleaded with Germany to allow the
transfer of their tanks you may with
your German counterpart yesterday and
like you said today they still have not
made a decision are you um disappointed
in the German position and how can
Germany still be seen as a reliable Ally
given what is widely perceived as them
dragging their feet on something so
simple and for the chairman um
is there any prohibition on the use of
American weapons by the ukrainians in
Crimea currently and you've talked about
how this war like many others has to end
through a negotiated settlement is now
the time for the Russians and ukrainians
to come to the table to talk about that
um thanks leaders first let me say that
uh
this isn't really about one single
platform
and so our goal and I think we've been
fairly successful at doing this and
bringing together capability
is to is to provide the capability that
Ukraine needs to be successful in the
near term and so you've heard us talk
about uh two battalions of uh Bradley uh
infantry fighting Vehicles very capable
platform
um
three battalions or a brigade's worth of
uh Strikers uh so you add that up that's
that's two brigades of combat power that
the U.S is providing along with enablers
and other things so you look at Sweden
providing a battalion of CV 90s that's
an armored personnel carrier the Germans
are providing Martyrs uh the uh the
polls are providing a battalion's worth
of uh mechanized capability you heard
the chairman highlight uh four
battalions of uh of artillery mechanized
artillery that's being provided so this
is a this is a very very capable package
and they you know if if uh if employed
properly uh it will it will enable them
to be successful now we're going to
ensure that we're doing everything
necessary to ensure that they have the
ability to employ it properly now you
heard us talk about training additional
training that we're going to do this is
something that we haven't been able to
do in the past cash so you know as we
speak you know troops are being linked
up with uh Bradley infantry fighting
vehicles uh and they'll train for weeks
not only on just how to operate the
vehicles but also uh on how to properly
set conditions for maneuver and then
maneuver and then you know how to
exploit uh opportunities how to breach
obstacles uh so I think this will be a
really really capable package that we
put together and I really do believe
that it will enable the ukrainians to be
successful going forward so this is not
dependent upon a single platform this is
uh this is a combined arms effort that
we brought together that I I truly
believe is going to provide them the
best opportunity for success
and there's the uh
on your first question uh typically
we're not going to discuss I don't
discuss either prohibitions or
permissions authorities on the use of
weapons Etc that's that goes towards
Rules of Engagement we don't typically
discuss those in in a public forum on
the second question
President Biden uh president zielinski
and most of the leaders of Europe have
said that this war is likely to end in a
negotiation and and from a military
standpoint this is a very very difficult
fight this fight stretches uh all the
way from right now is the front line
goes from all the way from car to keep
down to kirison and the significant
fighting ongoing and it's more or less a
static front line right this minute with
the exception of Bachman solidar with a
significant offensive action going on
really from both sides
the distance that for the United States
that's about from uh I guess Washington
DC to Atlanta so that is a significant
amount of territory and in that
territory uh are still remaining a lot
of Russian forces in russian-occupied
Ukraine so from a military standpoint I
still maintain that for this year it
would be very very difficult to
militarily eject the Russian forces from
all every inch of Ukrainian occupied or
Russian occupied Ukraine that doesn't
mean it can't happen doesn't mean it
won't happen but it'd be very very
difficult I think what can happen is a
is a continued defense stabilizing the
front I think it's possible to to
clearly do that and I think it's uh
depending on the delivery and training
of all of this equipment I do think it's
very very possible to for the ukrainians
to run a significant uh tactical or or
even operational level offensive
operation to liberate as much Ukrainian
territory as possible and then we'll
then we'll see where it goes but I do
think at the end of the day this war
like many wars in the past will end at
some sort of negotiating table and
that'll be determined in terms of timing
by the leaders of both countries uh both
both Russia and and Ukraine uh President
Putin could end this war today it's he
started it it's his war of choice and he
could end it today uh because it's
turning into an absent catastrophe for
Russia massive amounts of casualties
lots of other damage to the Russian
military Etc uh so he should and could
in this war right now right today
thank you our next question will go to
Anson Stan zdf thank you very much Mr
secretary is Germany doing enough in
order to show real leadership in Europe
thank you
yes
but we can all do more in uh you know
the United States and every other member
of the UDC can can do more you know
Germany has contributed a lot to this uh
to this campaign uh you know from the
very beginning we we saw the cycle in uh
air defense capability the gephards uh
the Patriots most recently rst
they've stepped up and offered to
provide the martyrs they will provide
those Martyrs and conduct the training
on those platforms uh and uh
we are training uh Ukrainian soldiers on
uh on maneuver and other things uh and
Specialty things uh here uh in Germany
as well so Germany's open it continues
to open its doors and and make the
training areas and Facilities available
for us to continue to do the work that
we need to do and Germany is also
training uh troops and training uh
Battalion and Brigade headquarters so
you know they have a big ore in the
water like the rest of the contact group
does uh and uh and they're working hand
in hand uh with with uh with the rest of
our colleagues here so I think he just
asked me uh earlier uh if
if if Germany uh was uh was a leader was
that the right question there you just
oh yeah okay yeah they are reliable Ally
and they've been that way for for a very
very long time and I I truly believe
that they'll continue to be a reliable
Ally going forward uh not to mention uh
they have uh Germany is host to 39 000
of my troops and their families uh and
also 10 000 civilians here and and so
we've had a great relationship
throughout over the years and I will
continue to have that that great
relationship and Germany will continue
to exercise leadership going forward
thank you our next question will go to
Dan lamothe Washington Post
anything gentlemen uh thanks for your
time today uh secretary Austin a number
of lawmakers and observers have said
that at this point makes sense to send a
small number of Abrams Tanks if only to
encourage Germany to unlock the leopard
tanks that they have not sent is that
feasible and if not why not and for the
chairman police given the amount of
armor of the United States and allies
are sending at this point how confident
are you that they can put together a
coherent offensive in the coming months
to what extent to the extent you can
what that what what might that look like
and separately you just reference the
large number of casualties can you give
us any update on what you're seeing at
this point for casualties on both sides
thanks
um I think you heard a German uh
Minister of Defense say earlier today
that there's no linkage between
um
providing m1s and providing uh leopards
and I think he was pretty clear about
that so this notion of unlocking you
know I in in my mind is not it's not an
issue and more importantly in his mind
as well and in terms of providing
capability
what we uh in the in the department
always look at is you know providing
credible combat capability we we don't
do things uh to or employ uh
capabilities as a notion you know as a
as you know for for anything other than
providing credible combat uh capability
and that's where our Focus will be in
the in the future whatever we do
whatever we employ so
so Dan on the uh
in order to execute a successful
offensive operation at the Tactical
operational level which is really what
we're talking about here for the
ukrainians uh you've got to not only man
the unit which the ukrainians had the
Personnel but they have to be trained
and so they're going to be married up
with the equipment and then they got to
be trained
um and if you look at the weather and
terrain Etc
um you can see that you have a
relatively short window of time to
accomplish both those key tests so
that's very very challenging to do that
for all these different nations that
were here today to assemble all the
equipment get it all synchronized get it
get the Ukrainian troops trained
Etc uh that'll be a very very heavy lift
so confident uh yes I think it can be
done but I think that it'll be a
challenge there was no question about it
so we'll see I don't want to predict one
way or the other but the Ukrainian
forces so far have executed at least two
and perhaps even more than that very
successful offensive operations one up
around dark Eve Crossing the Asheville
River in in over in to uh in in into uh
the Russian lines to the uh east of the
uh of kartikey and then they've run a
very successful operation down in
kirison uh so it remains to be seen But
the equipment's getting married up with
the people people got to get trained on
the equipment and all that's going to
have to get shipped in into Ukraine Etc
all put together uh inside of a coherent
plan uh obviously General zaluzzi and I
and others have uh uh discussed uh what
his Visions were not an executable level
detail yet but uh he's working on that
and uh and we'll see which way it goes
uh in terms of uh casualties you know
the numbers of casualties in War are
always suspect and and but I would tell
you that the Russian casualties the last
time I reported out on it publicly I
said it was well over a hundred thousand
uh I would say it's significantly well
over a hundred thousand now so the
Russians have suffered a tremendous
amount of casualties in their in their
military uh and and that includes the
regular military and also their
mercenaries in the Wagner group and
other type forces that are fighting with
the Russians they have really suffered a
lot now you saw that the Russians uh did
a call-up uh called out I think called
up an immobilization uh 300 000 I think
they were able to get maybe 200 250 000
stuff in that range uh so they're
replacing their losses in terms of
Manpower but they have suffered a huge
amount uh Ukraine has also suffered
tremendously you know that uh there's a
significant amount of innocent civilians
that have been killed in as a result of
the Russian actions uh the Russians are
hitting civilian infrastructure uh
there's a significant amount of economic
damage significant amount of damage to
the energy infrastructure and the
Russian or the Ukrainian military has
suffered a significant amount of
casualties themselves so this is a very
very bloody war and there's significant
casualties on both sides and this is why
I say that I think that uh sooner or
later this is going to have to get to a
negotiating table at some point uh in
order to bring this to a conclusion and
that will have to happen uh when the end
state which is a free Sovereign
independent Ukraine with his territory
intact is met when that day comes then
people sit down and negotiate an end to
this but there's been a huge amount of
suffering on both sides
ladies and gentlemen that is all the
time we have available today Mr
Secretary General Malik thank you both
gentlemen this concludes our press
briefing thank you